just stop oil protesters helped down
from the QE2 bridge in Dartford by Essex
police
they'd been up at a precarious height
for two days demanding an end to all new
fossil fuel production in the UK and
forcing the closure of the Dartford
Crossing and causing huge delays do you
feel sorry about that I'm not sorry for
trying to protect the land the
suffragettes were widely hated by most
of the population and for decades they
did extreme much more extreme acts of um
Disobedience destroying buildings post
boxes blowing things up
sometimes people hate the thing that
that needs to happen the bridge protest
just the latest in a string of incidents
across London
earlier in the day there was anger when
a group blocked the busy A4 an arterial
route west of the city
eventually more than 20 protesters were
unglued from the tarmac and arrested
whether blocking busy roads or climbing
Bridges the protests across London have
so far mainly been fairly typical of
just stop oil that is designed to cause
maximum disruption but the group's
tactics are escalating too and they now
seem interested not just in
inconveniencing people but shocking them
as well
this stunt at the National Gallery was
designed to do just that
Van Gogh's sunflowers painting was
protected by glass but the point was to
generate outrage and attention
for this prominent climate scientist it
was too much for most people they will
only remember that activists have tried
to vandalize one of the most famous
paintings of Van Gogh
to some extent I would say that search
action is a little bit selfish and
egotistic the government is trying to
expand police Powers against protesters
but it's unlikely to impact just stop
oil or their controversial methods
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News